wegzuschauen heißt mitzumachen machen
wir ausreichend machen wir genug hier in
deutschland haben wir die versprochenen
waffen eigentlich alle geschickt große
zweifel daran heute der berichte über
die nach wie vor ausstehenden
waffenlieferungen hier aus deutschland
versprechen die noch nicht ausreichend
eingelöst wurden seitens des
verteidigungsministeriums seitens der
verteidigung des ministerin christine
lambrecht zunehmende kritik an ihr
deswegen nicht mal das geliefert zu
haben was man versprochen hat darüber
wollen wir sprechen mit florian hahn dem
verteidigungspolitischen sprecher der
union schönen guten tag herr hahn
diese worte ein herzliches grüß gott
druck aus münchen die klingen hier nach
im studio die können wir heute nicht
einfach so abschütteln das war so
eindrucksvoll so nachdrücklich so
emotional und jetzt erfahren wir
gleichzeitig dass wir als deutschland
die bundesregierung die versprechen noch
nicht eingelöst hat was fällt ihnen dazu
ein
ja es ist weiter wirklich
beschämend im grunde dass wir seit
beginn dieses konfliktes und dann auch
sogar auch nach dem kriegseintritt
russlands nach dem überfall auf die
ukraine ihr weiterhin immer uns
auszeichnen durch zögerlichkeit durch zu
spät sein und im grunde auch den
ukrainern das verwehren was sie jetzt
tatsächlich brauchen und das ist wir
müssen sie unterstützen bei ihrer
verteidigungsfähigkeit es ist ja richtig
dass wir
waffenlieferungen inzwischen machen aber
es alles mit viel zu geringem viel zu
geringer geschwindigkeit es werden
listen nicht bearbeitet es gibt eine
große diskrepanz zwischen dem was
beispielsweise die aussenministerin
berbalk die sehr aktiv ist das will ich
ausdrücklich sagen aber was sie
verkündet im deutschen bundestag und was
tatsächlich dann unterm strich auch
ankommt und sie hier gibt es große
probleme in der bundesregierung diese
probleme scheinen vor allem im
bundesverteidigungsministerium zu liegen
denn dort liegen im wahrsten sinne
listen rum hier prüft man sich zu tode
während die ukraine um ihre leben
kämpfen
aber es ist doch wahnsinn man prüft sich
zu tode der liegen listen und wir
liefern falsche waffen also waffen die
man dort im moment überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen kann und während man das tut
sterben dort die menschen so kann es
doch nicht weitergehen das kann doch
nicht unser ernst seien
absolut und sehr wir rühmen uns auch
noch ständig dass wir angeblich der
zweitgrößte lieferant von waffen sind
das ist mitnichten nicht so die usa
liefern deutlich mehr das vereinigte
königreich
liefert deutlich mehr die türkei selbst
estland liefert deutlich mehr also es
ist wirklich ich kann mir da nur an den
kopf fassen und das parlament das ja
eine kontrollfunktion hat wird hierbei
total behindert durch völlig durch
geheimhaltungs regeln die vorgeschoben
werden meine partei die union hat für
diese woche eine sondersitzung gefordert
am vergangenen montag weil wir die
diskrepanz aufklären wollten zwischen
dem was verkündet wird und was
tatsächlich ankommt das hat man hat die
ampel-koalition abgebügelt und gesagt
nee das wir haben ja nächste woche eine
sitzungswoche da kann man mal in ruhe
darüber reden ich will nur sagen in der
ukraine geht es um jede stunde und das
hat ja klitschko ganz klar und deutlich
gemacht eindrücklich und wir können die
dinge einfach mal so eine woche
verschieben also dafür fehlt mir jedes
verständnis ich finde das ein echtes
kann ja in der tat also wie kann man
überhaupt noch schlafen gehen wie kann
man als ministerin schlafen ruhig abends
ins bett gehen wenn nicht die liste
abgearbeitet wurde das kann doch
eigentlich gar nicht sein also man das
ist doch weltfremden wir hören gerade
hier den vize bürgermeister von mario
pohl wir haben hier im studio wladimir
klitschko gehabt wir sehen seit über 30
tagen seit über einem monat diese
zerstörung man kann doch nicht an
schlafen gehen abends wenn das nicht bis
zum letzten abgearbeitet ist bis nicht
sichergestellt ist dass das geliefert
ist
mir scheint auch so dass die ministerien
er einen eintopf job meint angetreten zu
haben statt jetzt in dieser krise
tatsächlich
mit nachdruck dabei ist die dinge
umzusetzen man muss sich vorstellen dass
die ukraine inzwischen direkt auf die
deutsche wehrtechnische industrie zu
geht um hier direkte geschäfte
abzuschließen und dass ein grüner
minister wir haben tatsächlich derjenige
ist dafür sorgt dass schnell genehmigung
kommen damit das dann tatsächlich
passieren kann aber die dinge die im
bundesverteidigungsministerium sind die
werden auf eis gelegt mir völlig
unerklärlich und hier erwarte ich auch
von bundeskanzler endlich eine harte
hand und geordnete hand danke herzlich
für das gespräch
florian hahn innenverteidiger gerne ein
sprecher der union da keene
vielen herzlichen dank und wenn man